so let's answer the question is it
possible to gain muscle mass when you're
doing in a minute fasting let's say you
want to get the benefit of doing in a
minute fasting yet you also want to gain
muscle how would you do it well there's
several factors here sometimes people
have this idea that they have to spike
insulin to grow their muscles so they're
gonna do carbo-loading because after all
if you stimulate carbohydrates you'll
trigger insulin and insulin is an
anabolic hormone makes sense right but
in reality when you stimulate insulin
that much or too much you create insulin
and resistance and if you have insulin
resistance
you can't absorb amino acids that well
anymore this is why a pre-diabetic
or a diabetic or someone that has
insulin resistance doesn't absorb
protein or amino acids that well so here
you are trying to gain muscle mass but
all this glucose and this insulin is
creating a resistance to that protein
going in your body there's this product
called serious mass and I have a picture
of it right here or you're supposed to
take this product and bulk up right two
scoops is 252 grams of carbohydrates
this is two scoops and the first
ingredient is multi dextran okay this is
way worse than sugar it's way worse than
hyper just corn syrup it's like 110 on
the glycemic index so what's gonna
happen you are going to bulk up but you
are gonna bulk up with a lot of fat this
is going to spike your blood sugars and
create a lot of complications alright
let's talk about some other factors I'm
gonna recommend you do two meals a day
okay if you're trying to develop more
muscle mass not one meal a day but two
meals a day and at the very minimum do
intermittent fasting 16 hours so you're
basically fasting for 16 hours and you
have an 8 hour eating window so let's
say your first meal is at 10:00 in the
morning and your next one is at 6:00 and
you can do any pattern you want but just
starting out this would be the very
minimum to start seeing improvement
because
we want to do in a minute fasting to
spike growth hormone but as you do it
you want to start increasing this more
in more and more and more until you get
to a point where this fasting is 21
hours in a three hour eating wind out if
possible we also have to make sure that
there's enough calories in your meals
too because if your meals just don't
have enough food it's gonna be really
hard to grow muscles so you're gonna
have to determine how many calories you
need but the average person will
probably need somewhere around 1,500
calories per meal or a little bit more
alright the next thing that's really
important is exercise volume exercising
enough using heavy weights really
working your body to the point where you
are getting sore and you're creating
change all right number three
carbohydrates maybe you want to keep
your carbs on the high end but not go
over 50 grams well depending on your age
let's say you're younger maybe you do 60
grams maybe even 70 grams but don't go
any higher than that that way we get the
benefits of ketones so you've been
consuming enough carbs to keep normal
insulin so when you do a low carb diet
in a minute fasting we're not bringing
this down to zero if all we're doing is
bring it to a normal range so you're
still gonna have the anabolic effect of
insulin but you're just not going to
have the insulin resistance so as you do
this you're gonna have the benefit of
absorbing Meuse amino acids too so that
brings us to number four having a
complete protein branched chain amino
acids are not complete you cannot build
muscle protein with just a partial
profile of amino acids you need the most
complete protein and the best protein
out there it would be the egg protein
okay fish is good there's other types of
essential amino acid blends especially
when you're taking them when to fasting
just to really make sure 100% that
you're not actually losing any muscle at
all but that being said if you're
fasting 16 hours up to 21 hours you're
not going to be losing any muscle and
also make sure you have enough amino
acids so 6 to 8 ounces per meal
depending on your age if you're a little
younger and you're more active maybe you
do 9 ounces per meal
now nutrients you don't just build
muscle
with protein you need other nutrients
calcium B vitamins magnesium vitamin D
potassium very necessary and this is why
you want to do the healthy version of
keto some other factors that can slow
you down is having high cortisol that's
a stress hormone and that can come from
not sleeping so sleeping increases
growth hormone and cortisol inhibits
growth hormones so this is one way to
really create a loss of muscle mass and
this is one problem with women going
through menopause is the adrenals are
backing up the ovaries and there's a
spike in cortisol and a lot of times we
have a loss of muscle and it looks like
fat but it's atrophy so cortisol is very
very destructive on your muscle so you
want to keep your stress as low as
possible now if you're doing prolonged
fasting
I wouldn't go past 72 hours if you're
trying to maintain your muscle mass not
that it's going to be a problem but if
you're new to this if you go too long
and you don't have enough reserve built
up it could create a little loss of
muscle alright guys there you have it
these are the factors to help you
maintain and even grow more muscle mass
when you're doing intermittent fasting
if you're new to my channel check out
this video in a minute fasting it will
give you everything you need to know
about how to do it
healthily